good morning John Parks and Rec was an
extremely special television program not
only was it hilarious it was also
friendly and kind and thoughtful and
full of people who disagreed but enjoyed
each other and this is highlighted in a
relationship between two main characters
who could not disagree more politically
miss bad business is good free market
Miwa more pointless social program yummy
yummy you disagree a lot they disagree
on politics and on friendship I'm not
interested in caring about people and
weapons at work literally everything is
a weapon son and marriage reception will
be held in each of our individual houses
alone pretend this is rice and they
fight Lots but Leslie Knope and Ron
Swanson do not hate each other hello
former strange person I used a friend
okay they did for a little while but
mostly they don't they have very
different worldviews but they are both
and this is important and recognized by
everyone who watches the show good
people and they recognize each other's
goodness this is not house of cards in
which as far as I can tell there are no
good people to think about Ron and
Leslie is that their politics are far
enough outside of the poisoned political
discourse that they don't ever disagree
about the classically politically
charged issues of the day Ron Swanson
isn't a member of the NRA probably
because he wouldn't give them his
address are you sure you want me to cut
up this card it gets you into the
parking garage I'll be taking the bus
now and I'll be paying in cash this is a
nice dramatic device because of course
Ron doesn't believe the government
should regulate guns but he also
probably doesn't believe the government
should regulate abortion or gay marriage
because he doesn't believe the
government should regulate anything my
idea of a perfect government is one guy
who sits in a small room at a desk and
the only thing is allowed to decide is
who to nuke likewise Leslie is in the
trenches of local government and though
she is clearly deeply progressive and
liberal and a huge fan of Joe Biden you
must be Leslie know what she isn't
talking about gun control or immigration
she's just trying to make the parks
department work which means that the
politics of the show while clearly
liberal are also disconnected from these
extremely tense and seemingly
intractable political debates which
makes it more believable that two people
with such different belief systems could
come to be close friends we're gonna
hate each other
I don't think so I think we're gonna be
fine but it says something about the
discourse in the US right now that this
distance from reality needs to be
created in order to build a believable
friendship between two people with
different politics even in a sitcom
it helps us believe that beneath it all
there's something that works here and
that thing I think is just respect they
value each other's convictions even
though they don't always share the same
goals and they almost never share the
same opinions except about breakfast
food why would anybody ever eat anything
besides breakfast food people are idiots
largely nowadays there's so much more to
the issues than the issues an attack on
a government policy or an action of a
new policy can feel like an attack on
our identity an attack on us but Ron and
Leslie are able to move beyond that and
share the world with each other and they
shared it respectfully and with kindness
and the ability to value each other
despite their differences in the u.s.
we're finding that harder and harder to
do and the deeper we get into this
election season the harder it's going to
get we see the opposition more than ever
both monolithically and negatively you
can live your entire life without
knowing a single person who would even
consider voting for the other side we
stay inside our bias affirming filter
and think that anyone who disagrees with
us must either be ignorant or evil it
would be nice if we could all be a
little bit more like Leslie and Ron
caring passionately about what we
believe in without demonizing those who
disagree with us and never never in my
life has that been more difficult John
I'll see you on Tuesday
ah